What do you even know about Zero?
Then tell me
what you know about him!
Tell me where Zero is now!
Come on, answer me!
Where is Zero?
I won't tell a traitor like you!
Then let's finish this here!
Don't get so full of yourself,
just because you can fly!
I've got you!
Eat this!
Now tell me! Where is Zero?
I hate pushy guys, you know.
I see. Then die here.
Any last words?
Lancelot Conquista, take off!
Taking off!
Kallen, I have to save Nunnally.
I won't ask you...
Impossible!
Kouzuki!
Pull the ejection lever, Kouzuki!
No use! It won't work!
I'm descending!
Forgive me, Guren...
Opening number 3 vertical launch chamber.
Connection signal with Guren Mk-II,
confirmed.
Turn around!
Linking up!
Fly!
Continue! Armor piercing ordnance
right arm unit!
Right arm unit dropping speed for linkup.
Transmission neuron 0.5 to 0.8 MMP.
No blockage detected.
Elastic muscles one through five
are operating normally.
Confirm activation of shock control.
Linking up.
No matter what the enemy throws at me!
If this new Guren can't
handle them, it's all over!
Still, you don't have much of a choice,
so why not try shooting?
You've got a point there!
From long range?
I can do it! With this
Guren Flight-Enabled Version!
Kallen, you're coming back,
in this situation?
Could Zero be inside the ship?
Get out of my way!
Have a taste of the Gefjun Net!
We have a countermeasure for this!
Even so, you're still stuck where you are!
Impossible! I thought
they upgraded my Yggdrasil Drive!
Suzaku!
We've located the viceroy!
She's in the garden space
to the rear of the main bridge!
But you only have
47 seconds till the ship crashes!
I promise, I'll save her!
Damn!
Confirm activation.
Activation, confirmed.
Guren!
Launch!
How do I turn this
into a close-range battle?
Kallen! Finish off Suzaku now!
Do that and nothing will stand in our way!
-Yes, sir!
It's too great...
The difference in machine potential!
I can't win.
Goodbye, Suzaku.
In that case...
In that case, what?
In that case,
you can't be allowed to live.
I'll defeat you and stop Lelouch!
I won't let you do that!
That's the reason
I've fought with the resistance!
You could have tried to work
within the system!
What are you supposed to do
if you can't get into the system?
How are we supposed
to tell people that it's wrong?
You!
How dare you act so high and mighty!
What about those who have no choice
but join the system?
What is justice?
Still, they say that war
is the mother of invention.
The people. The world.
They will never be
what we want them to be!
So now you're forcing them to be?
That's...
Even the radiant wave surger
is out of ammo now.
My shield energy is exhausted too.
Even so...
I can't beat her!
Even with the curse of the Geass!
Kallen, your strength is phenomenal!
My machine has better specs
than yours, yet...
Suzaku, even with all my strength...
Why?
Let's end it, Kallen!
If you only had justice on your side!
No.
Didn't it get him?
No, Kallen. You got me.
I see. You won, Kallen.
Kallen!
I'm going to stop you!
Goodbye, Lelouch.
Leave this to me! Get to Damocles!
You stubborn...
But you're no match for the Guren!
I'm glad that you care, Lelouch.
You have no country to defend!
Nothing to avenge!
You also don't have a shred of ambition!
If you have no reason to fight,
then why are you here?
I have a reason to fight. A promise.
Are you saying that you love Lelouch?
Who knows?
It's just that I thought it's time
for me to put an end
to simply accumulating experiences.
That makes you sound almost human!
Well done.
Kallen, you win.
That really doesn't matter.
Goodbye.
Win or lose, I never thought
I still had those feelings in me.